what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice subtracting
multi-digit numbers i'm going to use
1000 minus 528
as our example but it's really to
understand different methods and how
they all fit together and why it
actually makes sense so if you wanted to
visualize what this difference means
imagine something that is
has a length of a thousand some type of
units so its length right over here is
and we were to take away
528 from that so 528 from that is what
we take away and so this difference
would be well what do we have
left over so this is equal to question
mark
and i'm going to do it two different
ways i'm going to do it using a table
with place value and i'm also going to
do it using what's sometimes called the
standard method it's the way that people
often learn to subtract
numbers like this especially if we're
going to have to do some regrouping so
i'm actually going to do them
simultaneously for your benefit all
right
so let me just write out our table with
our place values so first of all you
have your thousands place
thousands
and let me square off the numbers here
that are in the thousands place so
that's i have 1000 right over there
that's one in the thousands place
then you have your hundreds place
hundreds
place
in this number i have zero hundreds
right now here i have five hundreds
and then you have your tens place
tens
zero tens
right there and
in the tens place
two tens right over there
and then of course you have your ones
place
ones
here i have zero ones here i have eight
ones now let me also rewrite these
numbers and i'm gonna do it using the
standard method so i have one thousand
and then i have zero hundreds
i have zero tens
and i have zero ones
and from that i am going to subtract
five hundreds
five hundreds two tens
two tens and eight ones
and
eight ones so let's do both of these at
the same time and let me make up make a
little bit of a table right over here
so that is my
table
so let's start with what we originally
have we have a thousand that's what
we're subtracting from
well on this table i would just
represent as that is one thousand
now we want to take five hundreds and
two tens and eight ones from it how do
we do that because right now we have no
hundreds we have no tens and we have no
ones
and with the standard method we have the
same problem because we start in the
ones place and we say hey we want to
take eight ones from zero one similar
problem here how do we take eight ones
here similarly we wanna take two tens
from zero tens how do we do that here
and the answer is regrouping what we
wanna do is break up this thousand and
so that we can start to fill in these
other categories it's like exchanging
monies that's sometimes an example used
so a one thousand is how many hundreds
well if we get rid of these thousands i
can break it up into ten hundreds so one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten and so that's equivalent of i could
get rid of this one thousand or this one
in the thousands place and give myself
ten hundreds
well that starts to solve my problem
because i could now take five hundreds
from this i could take five from ten
five hundreds from ten hundreds but i
still have the problem in the tens and
the ones place
and so what i could do is i could break
up one of these hundreds and into 10 10.
so let me do that so i'm going to take
let me do that in a color so i'm going
to take that one away and then that 100
is 10 tens 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. and if
i did that here well if i take away one
of the hundreds i'm now going to have
nine hundreds left
nine hundreds left but now i have ten
now i have
now i have 10 tens
so i'm in good shape now i can take some
tens here but i still don't have any
ones remember i want to take eight ones
from here so you can imagine what's
going on i could take one of my tens and
that's going to give me one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten ones
and so over here i could take away one
of my tens so i'm now going to have
nine tens
and
i'm that's gonna i'm gonna break that
into
10 ones
10 ones and so now things are pretty
straightforward what do i do
well i can now take my 8 ones from the
10 ones so 10 minus 8 that is going to
be 2. how would i represent that over
here i'm going to do the subtraction in
this yellow color well i want to take
away 8 of these ones so i take away 1 2
3 4 five six seven eight and i am left
with that two right over there that two
is that two
now i can move on to the tens place
if i have nine tens and i take away two
tens i'm gonna be left with 7
i'm going to be left with
7 tens how would we see it over here
well i have 9 10s left over i'm going to
take away 2 of them so take a 1 2 and i
am left with 7 is that seven one two
three four five six seven yeah that is
seven tens right over there we have two
ones seven tens and so this seven is
exactly this seven right over there
same
same colors
i think you see where this is going and
the whole idea is not just to get the
answer but to understand how we got this
answer so in the hundreds place if i
have nine hundreds and i take away five
hundreds then i'm gonna be left with
four hundreds same idea over here i have
nine hundreds i take away one
two three four five i am going to be
left with
four hundreds this four and this four is
the same
and so there you get the general idea
with the standard method it sometimes
seems like magic of how we're regrouping
things but all we're doing is we're
taking that thousand and saying hey
that's ten hundreds and then we take one
of those hundreds and we say hey that's
ten tens and then we take one of those
tens and we say that's 10 ones and then
we are able to subtract